i tweeted this recently just thinking
about how vine was the home of short
form vertical videos before it died in
2016. and now in 2022 tiktok has been
the most downloaded app on the planet
for like the last 12 straight months in
a row and short form vertical videos are
blowing up and i could reach no other
conclusion than
vine was ahead of its time
you might look at the electric vehicle
revolution that's happening right now
around us and think wow we have a lot to
thank tesla for
but tesla wasn't anywhere near the first
electric car that would technically be
in the
1890s but even in the 1990s there was an
electric car from gm called the ev-1 it
was this little two-door electric coupe
with a 55-mile range that sold less than
2000 units before being discontinued
removed from the road and crushed now of
course years later evs are on the rise
everyone's turning their car companies
entirely electric from the inside out
but no one remembers the gm ev1
because it was ahead of its time and so
that got me thinking there have been so
many products that have launched over
the years that have failed but just
because the world wasn't ready for them
yet and i have a few favorites that have
come to mind and so these are my top
favorite three gadgets that were ahead
of their time so number three google
glass
this one's a classic i think a lot of
people remember google glass but
probably forget some of the crazier
details so first of all this was back in
2013 nearly a decade ago
and they revealed it in the craziest way
they had skydivers literally jump out of
a blimp while streaming an entire
skydive live through google hangouts
straight from glass where they
eventually landed on top of the building
google i o is happening in then they
tore through the insides on bikes to get
up to this stage i mean that's a pretty
grand reveal for a pair of smart glasses
with a head mounted projection display
that would give you extra contextual
information about the world around you i
do remember this being the first
genuinely useful looking pair of ar
glasses though so you could see turn by
turn navigation in front of you with
google maps you could ask google
assistant questions with your voice and
just get it to show your results
anywhere you're at or it could show you
your notifications from your phone as
they came in that was super nerdy to
want to do all of this
hands-free all the time by wearing
something on your face but even at 1500
there was a lot of interest from nerds
like me but just general curiosity from
the public and google actually made this
explorer edition that was a super
limited edition run that would help them
test them in real life
but pretty quickly there started to
become problems i mean i guess the first
problem was that it looked
like this
which
you know i mean it's cool that you have
a camera and you can see like a first
person view of photos and videos of
things and share them
but this was 2013 and people were
absolutely not ready for people wearing
a camera and a computer
on their face it didn't have any sort of
visual indicator on the outside that you
were recording or taking photos so
people started getting kicked out of
movie theaters while wearing them
because security thought they might be
recording the movie and someone also got
pulled over in their car and ticketed
because the police thought they might
have been watching a movie on google
glass but even if you could get past the
whole camera on the face thing like this
is what it would look like to talk to
somebody using glass you know the the
button up here the glancing up to the
side the touch pad if it wasn't like
obvious already it was kind of unnatural
to be talking to someone while doing
that eventually google killed the
project for consumers glass actually
does live on through an enterprise
version where it doesn't have to worry
about looking like an everyday pair of
glasses acceptable to wear in public but
you can actually buy google glass
enterprise edition 2 right now for your
company where you can do live video or
give step-by-step instructions on how to
assemble things stuff like that but the
point is it got utterly rejected by
regular people by the public and we
haven't seen it for years but it's 2022
now and it's very clear that head
mounted displays vr and ar are all again
right on the horizon and about to
explode again snapchat has made multiple
versions of their spectacles that let
you share the world from your first
person perspective that's a camera on
your face facebook partnered with ray
bans to make some sunglasses that record
video and photos that's also a camera on
your face and apple of course has had a
rumored ar or vr headset for what feels
like years now probably coming out in
the next year or two and knowing apple
designed to be worn and accepted by
regular people and even at i o this year
kind of a callback google did a one more
thing and it was a pair of ar glasses
but this time focusing on live
translation so not quite the same thing
as google glass but still it's a start
google glass walked so these could run
they were for sure ahead of their time
alright so number two
was the samsung galaxy camera
so this is a bit of a lesser known
gadget some of you might remember it but
it was one of my favorite things ever so
i want to give it its flowers so this is
2012
this is the same year as the galaxy s3
but this is basically a whole mirrorless
camera with a galaxy s3 on the back so
this is a 16 megapixel camera with a 21x
optical zoom lens on the back all the
processing power of a galaxy s3 with a
quad-core chip on-board storage one gig
of ram and it was running the newest
version of android which at the time was
android 4.1 basically the only thing it
was lacking was an actual cellular radio
to be able to make phone calls if you
ask me
great product idea great idea like
obviously most cameras have pretty bad
uis as far as navigating through them
but even if they are pretty good they
don't have an internet connection and a
phone on the back and so how often are
you just trying to take a picture
and then do some quick edits in
lightroom and then put it on instagram
like just that quick workflow right
there all the time that's exactly what
this was built to do it had a smartphone
display it had great performance it had
the ui for it it was a dream so why did
this fail
well you could blame it on social media
being a little bit older you could blame
it on maybe a camera market being too
small at that time people didn't want a
dedicated camera but at the end of the
day the real reason was
turned out the camera wasn't that good
the actual quality of the photos
weren't that much better or easier to
take than a galaxy s3 in the first place
and so that's the reason the reviews
were terrible and nobody actually wanted
to buy the thing but in the background
it was very clear that a real camera
with a full android experience or a full
ui on the back made a lot of sense like
i said most camera uis currently pretty
bad and even if they aren't they sure as
hell can't edit a photo and then post it
on twitter or instagram fun fact android
was actually supposed to be
a digital camera os before it got bought
up by google and turned into a phone os
so really makes you think but i think
what it comes down to is basically
there's a friction to get something from
a camera to instagram there is taking
the photo and then wirelessly
transferring it to your phone maybe
which is either going to compress it or
it's going to take a long time and so
most people
most people would just take a photo with
their smartphone it's easy it's good
enough but for photographers for the
creator class or people enthusiasts like
myself that friction between getting a
good shot and putting it online
is the problem now there are other
cracks at solving this there were two
generations of the galaxy camera before
it was cancelled last year zeiss made a
camera called the zeiss zx1 it's a
full-frame camera with a fixed 35
millimeter f2 lens that ran android and
it also had lightroom mobile and
instagram pre-installed which let you
edit right there on the screen and
immediately post
but it was also six thousand dollars
which is entirely out of reach for most
people and also you couldn't install any
other app besides lightroom and
instagram and then there have been
plenty of attempts from companies to
make phones that have all the features
of a full-time camera so panasonic cm1
comes to mind this is from 2014 and this
had a one inch 20 megapixel sensor and a
28mm f 2.8 like a branded lens
definitely looked like a full-blown
camera but the rest of the phone wasn't
good enough to justify people buying
this one we even had sony try
add-on lenses for your phone so here's
another name for you sony qx10 i
actually owned one of these i never
reviewed it but it was a separate camera
and lens
that connects to your phone via
bluetooth and pairs via nfc
and just latches to the back of your
phone to give you a better camera but
even that was 250 dollars and didn't
work perfectly every time you know how
bluetooth is there's still so much
friction and again at the end of the day
most people totally fine with just the
smartphone camera for most stuff they're
putting on instagram i just did a video
on the sony xperia 1 mark iv if you
haven't checked that out already that
one has real optical zoom so it's a
better physical camera but again for
photographers creators enthusiasts
people like myself i maintain that we
are ready
right now
for a good
internet connected camera like
brainstorming out loud imagine an iphone
ui
on a real full-frame mirrorless camera
so a big sensor big lens but the
processing power and computational
photography with an m1 chip give this
thing on board storage give it usb type
c
please and then you can throw pro in the
name and
that would be great yeah i would want
one but until then
yeah galaxy camera was ahead of its time
so then number one last but not least
is the motorola atrix does anybody
remember the motorola atrix this was a
smartphone it was a first phone with a
dual core tegra 2 processor and it was
the first android phone with a
fingerprint sensor powerful stuff but
most importantly it could connect to
something called the motorola lap dock
to give you a full laptop experience
powered completely off of your phone
it's like whoa wait a second what is a
computer right i think we all basically
like the general idea the concept that
you only buy one computer and then you
plug this one smallest computer into
bigger and bigger shells to become a
bigger and bigger form factor and a
bigger and bigger computer because it's
so powerful at its core right that idea
is dope but there's two pretty big
hurdles towards actually achieving that
power
and software so motorola with the atrix
they attack the software problem head-on
right so their version of android was
called moto blur and when you plugged it
into the lap dock immediately that would
turn into an experience pretty similar
to what we have with samsung dex now
full-on laptop looking thing a dock apps
windows the whole deal but the tougher
challenge was definitely power right so
this phone came out in 2011. the first
dual core chip in any smartphone was a
pretty big deal at the time but let's be
real it's not powerful enough to be a
full-fledged laptop photo editing video
editing all that stuff much less even a
chromebook at that time and so this
actually kind of creates a third problem
on its own basically which is if you buy
into
this ecosystem this version of that idea
you're kind of stuck this atrix costs
200 bucks on a two-year contract but
then the lap dock cost 500 extra dollars
for basically a shell with a keyboard
and a screen and a battery if you
upgraded your phone you could no longer
use your laptop so the atrix didn't hit
right but now in 2022 the computing
power in smartphones has come a long way
people you know in benchmarks and
reviews might think we're nitpicking and
seeing if there's a difference between
the snapdragon 8gen 1 and the triple
eight but really the fact is all the
extra headroom we're getting has way
more functionality besides just texting
and using the phone like normal it can
become a computer we also already know
the m1 chips powering the latest
macbooks right now are based on a14
bionic from the iphone just scaled up so
you can imagine plugging the smartphone
into a larger form factor even if it's
not a video editing machine still is a
very capable laptop web browsing machine
honestly even photo editing would
probably go very smoothly just like the
way we see it on ipads plus it's
obviously great having all your messages
but also all your apps and all your
files just with you all the time no
matter what machine you're using so this
idea definitely has legs for the near
future honestly the biggest problem that
i see or the biggest obstacle in the way
of it is still the ecosystem problem
specifically because
a company like apple would much rather
have you buy an iphone and an ipad and a
macbook than just to sell you one
computer that can be everything so there
are some third-party attempts at a
modern version of this there's a company
called next that makes the next dock
this is basically the same thing as the
atrix but over a usbc connection for
samsung phones
boom portable dex laptop but again
that's only for samsung phones so really
the fact that the whole ecosystem has to
play for this idea to work makes it much
harder than just one single gadget so
the atrix was for sure ahead of its time
and probably will be for a little while
longer but i like the possibilities here
i like where we're going with that one
either way
yeah vine
was definitely ahead of its time fine
walk so tick tock could run
all right thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace